time since the apollo program nasa is
shopping for a new lander to go back to
the moon
the agency is expected to choose from
three designs for its artemis program
this month and three companies are now
competing for their chance to make
history so this first one
is from blue origin it's founded by jeff
bezos whose design is focused on
eventually operating on the moon
permanently so its propulsion system is
based on water because ice at the moon's
south pole could someday be converted
into rocket fuel
both hydrogen and oxygen are available
on the moon
in the form of ice in the polar regions
and our vision
is based on developing those lunar
resources in the future
to make these systems reusable instead
of bringing everything from earth
not crazy the other two competitors are
from spacex with its starship
inspired lander and there's another
approach from dynetics they're based out
of alabama
now nasa needs to choose which design
will take americans back
to the moon